these thousands of players are competing
in six deadly challenges and whoever
survives the longest wins fifty thousand
dollars start the first challenge
yeah the thousands of players are now
going there's so many people in front of
me i can't see the ground now this first
game is an obstacle course of climbing
jumping and dodging moving blocks well
lava is literally chasing you and if
they die they're done wait we get one
life oh my god
oh it's rising the level's rising
[Music]
dude i'm actually kind of killing it
right now though guys i'm gonna take
this slow and steady rumor has it that
wins the race but how do you do this
part oh my god this slime launches you
oh my god you're ahead of me look at
just the giant hordes of people wait how
do you do this i don't know how you do
this part oh there we go there we go
there we go all right i'm doing really
good right now
oh i see the finish line i see it you do
i i'm not there yet
whoa the lava is rising they gotta go
quicker oh my god there's ice this is
terrifying
i can't see
i cannot see oh my god
what like the lava just spawned on me
what was i supposed to do there thank
goodness
come on go none of these people are
gonna make it
the love is rising i'm so close to the
end go go i made it i made it yes yes i
got it i got it i got it oh this is
coming down to the wire oh no oh no
[Music]
what is this guy doing i hate this guy
we started with 2 000 players and we
finished the first game with 699 our
second death game consists of eight
tiles the players have to pick a towel
to stand on and i might randomly implode
it
all right here we go all right guys guys
pick one pick one oh my god okay let's
go i'm on one right now because naruto's
here i'm picking eight i'm trusting
eight oh no what is this five i'm on
five wait bridges are dropping in ten
seconds i might pick number seven
actually this guy got three seconds to
get on the platform
i'm switching i'm switching he thought
he was being slick acting afk hey
chandler hey buddy no no what number are
you standing on seven are you sure
number seven yeah yeah all right well
number seven's getting blown up oh why
is my orange no
wait no way
[Music]
wait i'm on sex i'm alive all right
we're blowing up number five yo
oh they're flying
i survived
do the people up here still count as
surviving if your brain is big enough to
land right here you go on what's the
last number eenie meenie miney mo i
already blew up number four
oh there's a creeper oh man oh look at
all the people falling below the world
we split the remaining players into a
red team and a blue team and we're gonna
be playing king of the hill and
whichever team holds the middle the
longest moves on here we go here we go
go go go go go go everyone shift in the
middle the horde of blue people are
rushing at the horde of red people the
objective is to hold this square in the
middle longer than the other team all
right blue is in the lead they are
collecting points they all have sticks
with knockback
oh my god carl's going for it i thought
he'd stay back
[Music]
frick i just felt i fell i fell i fell
oh carl got knocked off chandler's team
is winning carl and fundy are getting
destroyed shift and swing shifted swings
blue is dominating oh we're doing it oh
here we go here we go here we go here we
go go hey take over the middle blue
let's go
oh i fell no red is taking back over
blue we lost the center we got to get it
back yo red team is just camping
hardcore we are dominating right now
look at us 47 seconds remain blue is in
the lead but red has it i don't know if
blue's gonna be able to break their grip
red might make a comeback we're about to
take the lead all right red overtook
them 20 seconds left it's anybody's game
right now it could go either way yo look
at all these blue people just jumping in
on them oh oh they're getting back oh
ten seconds girl no they're back we're
just gonna knock them off go go
[Music]
yeah
yes let's go
had a red team come back and with that
half the server has been wiped our
fourth death game is an obstacle course
that requires some cooperation whichever
team has a player touch the finish line
first wins server begin the challenge
go go go go let's go let's go let's go
in this game they have to collect the
sand and then use that to pillar up and
go through the hole get all the blocks
there are blocks getting absolutely
wasted no no missing what's happening
right now oh yellow team's through
they're dying from fall damage now and
unlike the last challenges they die they
don't respond it's for 50 grand don't
fall right here we're doing great okay
we're getting actually quite far the
yellow team is not working together at
all all right so this one gotta mine all
this sand to open up the pathway to walk
through okay i made it we just need one
person to make it through that's all we
need how do you do this we're gonna make
a pillar we're gonna make like a
staircase make a staircase
oh my god i almost just fell off that's
terrifying
oh god it was a scary jump to make man
once they made it through they were then
challenged with the maze well you have
to mine the sand to go to the next
section oh my gosh i am stuck right now
i'm so stuck okay go this way everyone
go this way just follow the sand wait
this guy thinks
[Music]
oh he jumped around it yo if he would
have fell he would have lost 50 grand
yo we're here first we're here first by
a lot just get a lot of sand and a
pillar up red is tearing down the final
wall and yellow isn't even there yet
my family is texting me you're winning
50 grand ignore the family right now oh
yellow made it through all right yellow
is now on the giant sand wall they don't
know which part of the wall the door is
on it's right here but they don't know
who will break first this is actually
scary
oh oh oh oh
oh red team made it we did it yeah
let's go
we must salute all the fallen members
that you lost during this challenge all
right screw the moment of silence next
challenge and now all the remaining red
players have been tp'ed inside of this
box server give the boys weapons
diamond sword there's a hundred people i
only need 10 in the final challenge
let's go murder come here mango you're
my first blood
dead
[ __ ] i'm sorry you don't get 50 grand i
feel so bad even though i'm smiling
cow chris just went right by me
[Music]
i just see people flying around this is
terrifying girl
no
why oh that was funny
there's now 49 players right here and
only one of them is walking away with 50
grand uh hey jimmy can i start hunting
sure why not yeah
it's time to hunt some people
[Music]
oh whoever this is done for
free oh carl no hey carl grab a sword
get to slaying
[Music]
gentlemen there's 16 players left we
only need 10. i'm chasing someone
yeah teamwork right there
oh someone jumped someone jumped i got
him i got him i got him i got the other
side i got the other side look at him he
doesn't know what's gonna happen bundy
oh he's a nerd two more remain oh
i got him one more one more one more
360.
[Music]
oh
three six eight
dead and now that we have ten players
left the ten remaining contestants will
be going head-to-head in this shrinking
arena are you ready
start the challenge server
as the challenge goes on the borders
will shrink oh what is this a team here
nolan i don't know about you but i think
trexter is gonna make it trexler's gonna
die first trexter sucks shrekster is
gonna win hey you might wanna look
behind you jj look behind you
dude i'm vouching for azure dragon
as your dragon just killed someone hey
if you're on the outer ring you need to
get down there
oh
joe has been eliminated
oh my god they got a second kill lancho
has the big brain strat sitting up here
he has played fall guys before five
players are mean when they're getting a
third kill 50 grand on the line weekly
no all right four players are made
oh no oh he's been eliminated
immediately they're teaming up against
azure 50 grand on the line
no
oh oh azure almost falls oh the zone is
shrinking i want a zero dragon to win
please i'm going first i'm going for
sewer i say he's almost done three hours
three yards the zone is getting so small
[Music]
but wait after reviewing footage it
turns out that desert was actually
eliminated earlier in the competition
and that means that zero dragon is the
real winner but because it was my
mistake i'm gonna take accountability
for it and i'm actually gonna give them
both 50 000 to make up for me messing up
thank you everybody for coming out
subscribe